自慢じゃないけど
今日2時間しか寝てないぜ
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
何と無く顔から伝わればいいと思うんですけども、
今すぐ寝たい！！
だがしかし、今日はやらなきゃいけないこともあるので
寝れないんですよね今は
なんですけど、ちょっとこう時間があります、今
なんで仮眠をしたいです
ぼく
ぼく、仮眠をしたい。
でも、仮眠をして今寝たらひょっとしたら
そのまま寝ちゃうかもしれない
永遠とね
永遠ではないですけど、こう長い時間
9時間とかがっつり寝ちゃうかもしれないけど
1時間だけ寝たいっていうタイミングなう。
なんです
でですね僕目覚まし時計に常に思ってたことが
あるんですけども
うるっせえええええ
うｒｒｒｒｒｒｒｒｒｒっせえ
いやほんとにうるさいと思いません？みなさんも
いや、目覚まし時計ねちゃんと時間に起きれるのは
いいんですけれども、
音がうるさくて不快なんですよね。やっぱり
その時みなさん、不快にならずに起きれる目覚まし時計があるのをご存知でしょうか？
こちら！！！
（開封の舞）
こちら！ブライトアップクロックⅡ
開けてみましょう！
うわあ長細いぞ
これ時計ですよちなみに
うおお
うわあ
うほっほ
すげえな！
はい、本体こんな感じになっております
ほら！一応ちゃんとここ時計になってるでしょ
で、こんな感じになっております。
これ何かといいますと
最近話題になっている
光目覚まし時計のめちゃくちゃ強いやつでございます
ネットでいろいろ調べた結果
これが、やっぱ光の強さもめちゃくちゃつよいらしくて、
最強の光目覚まし時計らしいです。
で、光目覚まし時計って何かと言いますと
目覚まし時計って基本的に音で鳴らすんですけども
これは、光で目が覚めるみたいでございます。
だから、うるさくないから
光だけでこう・・・
～♪
あぁ！
みたいな感じで起きれるのかな
ちょっとよくわかんないっす！
良くわかんないんですけども、なんかそんなイメージです
僕の中では。
一回つけてみようか。
わあ！来た来た！付いた付いた。
うわぁあああああ
眩しっ！！
眩しっ！！！
えっ、こ、これよ～
待って、これまさか
あっ、俺いけるわこれ
ハックション！！！
くしゃみが出るぞ・・・
すごいぞ！！
僕、太陽の光でしかくしゃみできないと思うんですけども
これ強すぎてこれでも多分くしゃみできる。
えぇっ！すごいな
あぁぁ
はい、というわけで今からこれを使って
仮眠をしようと思うんですけども、
フッフッフッフッフ
ハッハッハッハッハッハッハ
ハッハ
寝不足の僕はこんなんじゃおきません。
ということで、今回は僕こちらの光目覚まし時計を
たくさん準備しました。
10個準備しました！
今から僕仮眠して、多分起きないっす！！
もうこのまま今日寝ようと思ってるんですけども
果たしてこの大量の光目覚まし時計を一気につけると
どれ位の光の強さになるのか
もう光が強すぎてひょっとしたらもうなんか
もうどうなるか本当計り知れない位の光量が
寝ている僕を襲いこみに来ると思うので
今回ですね、僕は今から寝て大量の光目覚まし時計のパワーをこの身をもって体感してみたいと思います！
おやすみ！！！
～～～～～♪
はい、というわけで全部セットできました！
あの～～～
置いたところの感想・・・
なんか・・電力がすごそうですね・・・
ひょっとしたらこれ電気付く前に家が停電しちゃうんじゃないかという可能性が出てきました。
では、ちょっと時間の設定していきます！
～～～～♪
はいっ！というわけで無事
光目覚まし時計全部設定完了しました！
ちょっとしたら目覚ましが鳴るんで
僕ちょっとガチで今から仮眠します。
果たして、最強の光目覚まし時計の威力どれほどのものか
かかってこい（ｒｙ
地球のみんな！震えて眠れ！！
～～～～～～～～～♪
ピッ！
ピピピピピピピ
うわあわあわあわあわあ
ああ”
うわあああああああ
眩しい！！
眩しい眩しい！
マジで眩しい！！
ピピピピピピピピ
はい、というわけで
すげえなあ・・・
なんかすごい眩しくて最初死ぬかと思ったんですけど、
ジリジリジリってうるさくないから、
比較的多分気持ちよく起きられた方だと思います
うるさい目覚ましも、これにしたら、
ひょっとしたら快適に起きれるかもしれませんね。
ぜひ、使ってみてはいかがでしょうか。
おやすみっ